all mein name ist luca ist sieben uhr
morgens und ich bin es müde
kennt ihr das man im sommer duschen das
ist richtig heiß und man stehen unter
der dusche ist alles gute mehr kann man
aus dem sportler zu schützen
aber wenn man im winter im stall
wichtigkeit unter der dusche und eines
richtig schön waren die hübsche geht
außenbahn viel ähnlichkeit zwischen sind
beschissen es ist auf jeden fall gerade
7 uhr 30 wir sehr zeitnah halben
dreiviertel schon erwache ich hatte
schon schlafen geht zu beschlüssen und
ich fliege jetzt nach münchen weil wir
den ganzen tag pizza essen werden
[Musik]
voll geil alter die kammer hat sogar
seine handy halterung brokkoli auf einer
pizza menschen ziemlich abstoßen wir
sind in münchen angekommen meine lieben
freunde und wir sagen ich sage euch
jetzt was wir eigentlich machen nämlich
die coaches sind hier in münchen gleich
bei gustavo cousteau und der ein oder
andere wird costa musste noch kennen
denn das ist das unternehmen mit denen
ich bisher die bugspitze 1 und günther
bitzer 2 gemacht haben und mit denen
werde ich auch dieses jahr noch die liga
drei machen begeisterung
wir fahren jetzt auf jeden fall nach
geretsried das ist der ort wo gustavo
musst du die pizzen herstellt und wir
werden dort dann eigentlich heute fast
den ganzen tag pizza co star oku sda
wir werden hinter träume wahr vor san
luca pizza 3 gegen haben wir dann erst
mal eine rundtour durch die neue
produktionsstätte von bewusster gemacht
also ihr seht hier nochmal wie die ihre
pizzen herstellen der mir schon unsere
mittel und sicherheitsschuhe angezogen
ich brauche noch eine firma
wäre alles per hand gemacht hier werden
die fetzen anpacken schablonen gelegene
packen die leute dann die so schon drauf
aber schweine das alles hier ist eine
partie back kammer sei immer von open
source als 10.000 zu lassen
denn die pizza aus dem steinofen
rauskommt die sauce bei 300 grad
wir sind schon die koch doch so richtig
die freunde mit einem gleichmäßig der
käse auf der pizza verteilt und alles
was halt daneben liquidieren und konnte
wiederum oft darauf wird auch nicht
selbst verschwendet
wir fordern beispielsweise die salami
isst draufgelegt so doch mal ganz kurze
info das was hier gerade produziert wird
ist die pizza salami von gustavo gusto
also das ist nicht die luca pizza drei
produktionen die manns ja gerade
angeschaut haben kannst du interessant
wenn man so eine kleine rundtour durch
die produktionsstätte von bewussten zu
bekommen denn allzu langer zeit noch die
bugspitze 1 und 2 produziert haben weil
die produktionsstätte so viel kleiner
deswegen wollten uns das einfach noch
mal anschauen aber jetzt seht ihr dann
die fertigen pizzen wie sie eingepackt
werden dass wir sind auf jeden fall die
fertigen schützen und die werden davor
jetzt angepackt
hier kommen die pizzen dann noch mal
durch ein röntgengerät und jeder
einzelne pizza wird quasi genau
betrachtet und auch da vorne noch mal
einer
da wird angeschaut auf den kompletten
text von die durchgehend sind zum
beispiel hat alle unter prozent hier
werden die pizzen die kartons
automatisch eingeschoben sind sck lager
und hier sind minus 40 grad drin ist
versteht da seht ihr was hier abgeht und
wie viel ballett fast 1000 toiletten wie
viele pizzen sind auf einer palette vier
wänden zu hause ausreichendes lüften
hier stehen die tour durch die neue
produktion haben jetzt auf jeden fall
beendet
das heißt wir gehen jetzt alle zusammen
eine test küche mit es auf vielen
zutaten und schon die ganze zeit nur
noch pizza und gucken was die pizza drei
werden können wird ich bin doch dann
auch dass wir sind die ganzen zutat mit
dem er zum spielen werden
[Musik]
walter die haben auch mich hier einfach
hingestellt belegt jetzt meine pizza mit
irgendwelchen sachen die hier vorne
stehen und schreibt dann auch was drauf
ist und bleibt schmeckt aber vielleicht
auch nicht wenn ein paar schicken den
später so sieht meine pizza bisher aus
und die soße ist die bianca soße da ist
ricotta creme mit drin und dann haben
wir noch fünf käsesorten also insgesamt
sechs verschiedene käsesorten auf der
pizza
ich bin gespannt so mein gott leute
guckt euch das an
hey wie geld ex bitte auf nur wenige
minuten später
[Musik]
kraft es dass die sind einfach gerade
alle am pizza backen und rumprobieren
kind neben der heute schon das hier ist
jetzt locker gerade 16 pizza die wir
gewonnen haben aber alle wandler lecker
außerdem mit kartoffeln wir haben jetzt
gerade noch mal alle zusammen schönes
abschlussfoto gemacht und haben jetzt
tatsächlich 16 pizzen gegessen mit
dezent schlecht gerade aber ich glaube
wir haben schon so ein sehr sehr gutes
grundrezept gefunden wir müssen noch
genau gucken wieso die käsevariationen
sein wird aber es wird auf jeden fall
eine ziemlich ziemlich geile pizza der
flughafen geht erst mal halb zehn
jetzt haben wir allerdings das 1730 von
daher haben wir noch vier stunden zeit
bis der flieger geht von daher haben wir
jetzt dafür entschieden dass der zug
fahren ich fliege eh nicht so gern mag
und wir deswegen jetzt mit dem zug
fahren
wir stehen gerade am zug und der zug
hätte eigentlich vor elf jahren an
gestrichen worden wären tun sein müssen
summarum liegt aber im endeffekt nehmen
zufall mit judith und mit gulasch
es sind stunden zug gefahren wo wir sind
trotzdem er in köln das wären wir
geflogen werden also megatrucks wie
schnell wir tatsächlich fertig war jost
august so die bereits gesagt haben uns
heute alle zusammen in münchen beim
gustavo wirst du getroffen um einfach
den ganzen tag pizza zu essen und
zuschauen hey was könnte die duh kapitza
drei überhaupt für eine pizza werten
dies durch die pizza beat richtig
richtig geil wolle mich übertrieben
alter möchte euch gegenüber allerdings
dennoch komplett offen transparent und
ehrlich beinen haben von daher muss ich
euch natürlich auch sagen bei der
superflitzer zwei hatten wir diese
kleine plastik sache und danach habe
selbstverständlich ich mir auch die
frage gestellt halo kann möchtest du
kapitza 3 noch mit gustavo gust zu
machen überhaupt ich habe über diese
sache wirklich lange gedanken gemacht
und auch als ich jetzt heute wieder da
war hat es mal wieder gezeigt
denn tiefkühlpizza dank gustavo musste
weil ich sag euch mal ein paar sachen
über die der teig von jeder einzelnen
pizza wird ausgebreitet zudem wird jede
pizza danach auf einem steinofen
gebacken mozzarella ist laktosefrei und
gustavo kosten verzichtet konsequent auf
künstliche aromen künstliche betrieb
mittel und geschmacksverstärker außerdem
produzieren sie deutschlands größte
tiefkühlpizza mit einem durchmesser von
30 zentimetern aber komplett abgesehen
von der new kapitza 3 ist es
beispielsweise auch so wenn die jungs
von gustavo guckst du hier die pizza
tonno beispielsweise haben dann ist der
thunfische nicht irgendwie normaler
thunfisch oder gegen die so solltet
jetzt von hand auf den malediven oder
wenn sie beispielsweise auch pilze auf
eine pizza backen das ist das nicht
irgendwie pilz aus einer dose sondern
das sind frische pilze die die dort in
der produktion schneiden also die
qualität ist da so weit oben im
vergleich zu anderen alter ist normal
ich freue mich einfach
wir schrieben dass wir mit gustavo
musste jetzt auch die dritte luca peter
zusammen produzieren werden weil das ist
jetzt irgendwie keiner eingeschweißtes
team irgendwie so wir sind alle
eingespielt was das angeht und haben uns
auch heute alle mega gefreut sein alle
wiederzusehen und alle zusammen pizza zu
backen das war echt mega cool
das war echt nice ich bin einfach
irgendwie froh gerade keine ahnung das
möchte ich in dem blog ich so ein
bisschen zeigen ich freue mich total auf
di luca pizza drei der auch schon datum
und wir wissen jetzt auch sein heute was
auf die pizza darauf soll das werde ich
euch aber genau noch nicht alles sagen
soll dann erst wenn es wirklich alles
abgeklärt ist dass wir das auch so
überhaupt produzieren können apropos
produktion august away auf der erste
deutsche tiefkühlpizzen hersteller der
komplett klimaneutral produziert ja die
haben sich ihren co2 ausstoß berechnen
lassen und kompensieren dem dadurch dass
sie zwei große klimaprojekte angehen
das ist ich bin ja unfassbar stolz mit
ihm zusammen mit luca pizza dreimal zu
können ich freu mich so übertrieben auch
dieses projekt aber ich will nicht hilft
nicht weiter voll aber weltweit schon
genug gelabert an diese kamera von den
heutigen doch jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen
habe ich mich sehr über einen daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video hier
freuen und schreibt noch mal geld und in
die kommentare was ihr denkt was auf der
lu kapitza 3 an zutaten drauflegen wird
das finde ich echt mal interessant in
der infobox für weitere informationen zu
gustavo gusto und pizza und keine ahnung
was abonniert gern mal ein kanal
fahrzeughalters und jetzt kommt das auto
richtig billig mit so müde
[Musik]